Next up, our fellow cruise lovers out there,
we have huge news for you.
CNN reports that you can now make cruising your lifestyle.
That's right.
You can actually be living on a cruise ship.
Some retirees are setting sail for their golden years
by planning a wall-to-wall cruise.
One couple, the Burkes from Seattle,
have already booked 86 days at sea for 2022.
For just 89 bucks per day,
both of them get room, food, entertainment
and that includes gratuity and taxes,
and they get to see the world.
And you don't have to retire.
Some cruise lines are offering full residences at sea
and you can stay on their ship year round-
Mm-hm.
And bring your remote work,
'cause they have great wifi.
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
I love this.
Rossy, thoughts?
Season three on the seas?
All aboard.
Come on.
Oh my God.
(audience applauds)
You know.
Please, can we? Please, please.
Can I be the cruise director, please?
Put me to work, I'll do anything.
Like Julie?
Yeah, just like Julie, yeah.
Julie the cruise director.
I love you can go to Finland,-
Mm-hm.
And explore that area.
The cruise line industry,
I just think it's so amazing.
And again, if anybody's intimidated with planning,
I just feel like you get on,
you pick your destinations, they figure it out for you.
They kind of take that fear factor out of it.
I love it, I'm so in.
I'm so in, I feel like I was a man made to cruise.
You know how I love a buffet?
I do.
(audience laughs)
And I love visiting multiple locations
and unpacking one time.
That's why I love cruises, too.
And I did the math, so it's $89 a day.
So say you went for a month, around 30 days,
it is $2,670, that for two people,
that's room, board, buffet, those little towel swans.
Shows. A lot of the...
Piano bars, everything.
Pools, slides, uh.
I'll see you on board, everybody.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauds)
Let's go on a cruise.
Can you imagine us on a cruise?
I mean, we've RV'd.
We've been parked at this desk for two years.
Yes!
I'm serious.
Let's go on a cruise.
I can't think of anything more fun,
and anyone more fun to do it with.
I'm in.
I'm gonna get you a little lifesaver thing,
I'm gonna throw over you, matching me.
We're in, girl.
Can you imagine?
Captain hats.
Let's go cruising!
Well, next up our fellow cruise lovers out there,
we have huge news for you.
CNN reports that you can now make cruising your lifestyle.
That's right.
You're can actually be living on a cruise ship.
Some retirees are setting sail for their golden years
by planning a wall-to-wall cruise.
One couple, the Burkes, from Seattle,
have already booked 86 days at sea for 2022.
For just 89 bucks per day,
both of them get room, food entertainment,
and that includes gratuity and taxes,
and they get to see the world.
And you don't have to retire,
some cruise lines are offering full residences at sea,
and you can stay on their ship year round.
Mm-hm.
And bring your remote work,
'cause they have great wifi.
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
I love this.
Rossy, thoughts?
Season three on the seas?
All aboard.
Come on.
Oh my God.
(audience applauds)
You know.
Please, can we? Please, please.
Can I be the cruise director, please?
Put me to work, I'll do anything.
Like Julie?
Yeah, just like Julie, yeah.
Julie the cruise director.
I love you can go to Finland-
Mm-hm.
And explore that area.
The cruise line industry, I just think it's so amazing.
And again, if anybody's intimidated with planning,
I just feel like you get on,
you pick your destinations,
they figure it out for you.
They kind of take that fear factor out of it.
I love it.
I'm so in.
I'm so in, I feel like I was a man made to cruise.
You know how I love a buffet?
I do.
(audience laughs)
And I love visiting multiple locations
and unpacking one time.
That's why I love cruises too.
And I did the math, so it's $89 a day.
So say you went for a month, around 30 days.
It is $2,670, that for two people,
that's room, board, buffet, those little towel swans.
Shows, a lot of it's...
Piano bars, everything.
Pools, slides, uh.
I'll see you on board, everybody.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauds)
Let's go on a cruise.
Can you imagine us on a cruise?
I mean, we've RV'd.
We've been parked at this desk for two years.
Yes.
I'm serious.
Let's go on a cruise.
I can't think of anything more fun,
and anyone more fun to do it with.
I'm in, I'm gonna get you a little lifesaver thing.
I'm gonna throw over you, matching me.
We're in girl, can you imagine?
Captain hats.
Let's go cruising!
(bright theme music)